agence spatiale européenne a finalement
sélectionné six astronautes sur
plusieurs milliers de candidats pour les
missions de ces dix prochaines années
vers la station spatiale internationale
est peut-être là l'une parmi les six
sélectionnés figurent en français
patrick esther marque salido à 31 ans
thomas pesquet vient d'être sélectionné
par l' agence spatiale européenne pour
devenir astronaute
un choix drastique réalisé par me 8413
candidats au total cinq hommes et une
femme
une italienne sont officiellement
recrutés pour assurer les vols futur
vers la station spatiale internationale
né à rouen thomas est ingénieur supaéro
et pilotes d'airbus 320
hier soir ils ignoraient encore avoir
été choisi aujourd'hui il a du mal à
réaliser ce qui lui arrive
c'est quelque chose qui paraît un petit
peu irréel jusqu'à jusqu'à ce beau joe
ça vous arrive un peu un peu par
surprise
donc c'était c'était un rêve mais je
pensais pas vraiment pouvoir atteindre
un jour il ya des hommes qui paye 35
millions d'euros pour voler vous vous
allez être payé pour voler c'est un
privilège formidable oui tout à fait
sain pris la forme il a mais la grosse
différence c'est que vos volets
justement pour se faire plaisir juste
pour eux alors que nous on aura tout un
tas de d'expérience a réalisé 2 de
sciences à faire cette mission
scientifique européenne sont déjà
prévues jusqu'en 2020 à bord de la
station
alors les perspectives de vol sont
sérieuses elles permettent même à thomas
de rêver à une mission lunaire
on est donc maintenant six nouveaux
astronautes donc si tout se passe bien
on doit chacun avoir la chance de monter
au moins une fois pour ce qui est de la
lune c'est un petit peu plus lointain ça
passera forcément à travers la
collaboration et donc il faudrait une
volonté globale et pour monter une
mission internationale pour y aller les
scans inquira sur la lune
vraisemblablement et j'espère même
plusieurs puisque de toute façon là ils
ont trente deux ans de moyenne d'âge la
lune ce pendant 10 ans
ce seront encore des personnes jeunes et
en plus expérimentés à cette époque là
et alors pourquoi pas les pas de thomas
sur la lune
[Musique]